(upbeat Latin music)
- [Narrator] Colombia,
land of flavor and color.
But, few know about the incredibly rich
and unusual fruits this
country has to offer.
Thanks to its biodiversity,
the land produces delicacies,
like the prehistoric looking guanábana
and the mysterious mangostino.
And that brings us here.
This is not your typical
grocery store produce section.
This is Paloquemao.
Welcome to Bogotá's quintessential market.
This is the place to find
the most mysterious-looking,
strange-flavored fruits
across the palette.
(speaking foreign language)
(upbeat Latin music)
(laughing)
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] Paloquemao
is a special place,
bursting with color and flavor,
offering the world an irreplaceable
array of nectarous gifts.
Of course, as long as they're in season.
(electronic music)